Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to DOOM!
Now, I made it a point to go back and review the first episode that I made of this
that we released last time-
and also I read a lot of comments that you guy were talkin' about
And, I agree on a great number of things.
NUMBER ONE!
I don't think...I completed...a single thought the entire time I was playing last time.
Which is not good, because-
OHHHH MY GAHAHAHAD!!!
THAT kind of happened?
And,
I got distracted by how FRICKING AMAZING it was
I kinda got side tracked- OH MY GOD!
UHHU *low health beeps*
I mean, you could- you, you can't exact- uh-oh
I might die for the first time here, because
I'm...not paying attention.
Oops, I think I'm dead
Well, shit!
That was anticlimactic.
Anyway,
I got...distracted, like that, so
that was my first death.
And it will probably be one of my few deaths, because
Man! I shouldn't have run in there with the chainsaw blazing.
But, uh...
In the last video, I started a lot of sentences
And then I didn't finish 'em, because I got overly excited
about what was happening in front of me.
So in this episode I'm definitely gonna make a very, very,
VERY concerted effort to actually...use words good..
Which was not- OH...
*gets distracted and doesn't use words good*
THANK YOU FOR THE HEALTH JUICE!
Also, I'm gonna make a- uh, bigger effort to try to explore the environment some more
because that was another thing that I did not do, I didn't properly...uhh...
...like, see the areas that I was surrounded by,
I didn't explore, uh, very well.
And that led to me, uh, missing out on some things
and obviously missing out on some important details,
uhm, and important secrets because...
There is upgrade tokens that are
often in the secret areas,
which means that - whoa hey don't do that
Which means that there's uhm...
If I don't get everything that's available there,
it's gonna end up badly for me.
Oh shit that's not exactly what I meant to do
WhooAh-kay...Ahhh, there we go! That's what I wanted-
Because, uhm
another important detail that- when I actually read the tutorial
and I actually looked at the material in front of me
is that, you get more health when you do one of
these kills?
You get a lot of health, which was saving me in the last episode.
And!
You get a lot of ammo,
when you use the chainsaw to dismember people
into a million-billion pieces.
So that's important to remember.
Also, another fact that you obviously have seen already
but maybe have not noticed if you weren't paying too much attention-
is that, these episodes are not gonna be an hour long!
(BUT THE TIMESTAMP BEGS TO DIFFER MARK)
Because,
someone told me, that these-
that this game...
is sixteen hours long.
WHICH IS AWESOME!
But, y'know-
whoa hey
how's it going?
What are you doin'?
Okay?? Alright then,
[calling out to figure] Can I help you? Welcome to the party, you're a little-
ooookay?
Ah!
(monstrous groaning)
S-
uuh...
(ohhhhh.)
I can hear him!
So we went from over there to over there, is that supposed to be important for me?
Sorry, I'm spitting-
...okay, but
obviously I'm gonna try a better...uh, effort to look at the
environment to try to get an idea of where I'm supposed to be going.
So there's a connection error over there...to get into that area.
Which is hopefully gonna lead somewhere.
Ah, that was fue-
OOOOOHH?
AAAAH!!1!
WHAT THE FUCK?!
Sorry about that! In here-
okay, so
we're back! Sorry,
little thing,
technical difficulties that you don't need to worry about!
Y'know how let's playing is
"so difficult", and everything is so challenging.
so...
WHOOPS
aAAGH
That was not what I wanted to do.
I forgot how to crouch.
Because usually it's Ctrl,
but apparently that's the grenade button...
Because "G",
which is normally the grenade button in my mind...
iiiis...
[monster noises oh no]
wwhoa, hello...
Who's there?
Somebody down there?
ee-boink!
eheyeuheyhehe
Okay...one down.
((But what about the "G" button? Mark?))
Boink!
There's also a charge-shot built into this one...
(Viking-ish(??) accent)
which is pretty good fer hittin' them in the face.
...wait
that was- whoops!
GODDAMNIT
son-of-a
biscuit eating
biscuit eating...bitchaloid(???)
Okay,
let's try that again
Okay, we're gonna pretend like that didn't happen?
And I wanna know what you're doing over here and how
I can get over to another secret area..
Can I??
Noooooo??
Okaay.
(disappointingly)
Fine then.
boink
Please yes, thank you!
Nope he's just gonna explode into a million pieces.
Okay, so...
we're over in this area now,
I've got...
plenty of
...juice for my chainsaw
Apparently, you need five pieces of fuel to be able to kill
a bigger demon?
Which is important information for your everyday life.
But...I don't know how that's gonna help me here.
[Facility Voice: Access denied. Yellow security clearance required]
Ahh, screw you and your security clearance!
Who needs it?
[monster growls again oh no]
(mockingly)
Who wants it?
(over the grinding of the door)
Does anybody in here want a little bit of me?
...oh.
And also,
uh, for what little story there may be in this game
[Facility Voice: (???)]
I'm gonna do uh, a much better effort of actually trying
to find it.
Can you give me some health, please? Thank you,
how 'bout you?
No?
You're just gonna...pop into a million pieces-
boink-boink!
Well, that doesn't help me...
There we go.
Hiii!
Sorry for being late to the party!
Can I have some health thank you-
Man, this harder difficulty is probably gonna get wayyy,
way way more intense the farther I get into this game.
(Computer: (???))
'cause it-
Whoa.
Hello!
Oh, okay.
I don't know where I'm going I didn't even press the jump
button but it was just...kinda guiding me towards an experience.
I should prooobably have a better gun.
Like this one!
Boink!
Thank you!
Alright,
I gotta get the high,
high value dudes...
[low health beeps]
first-
Ow!
That's why.
holyshit
Whoa! Jesus, these guys-
thaank you.
Alright
there we go,
little bit more into it.
Got that guy.
Noo.
Got this guy, get some health outta him
boink,
Just add that
Uh-huh, thank you!
Alright,
It actually does take quite a bit of focus to be able to properly kill these guys...
properly, I mean, y'know
there's only one proper way to kill a demon
and that's to blow 'em up into as many pieces as possible, obviously.
[low health beeps]
Ow.
Son of a bitch,
boink
Heey, how's it going-
brrdrhrdrhrhrhroh hohohohOHOH
So many BULLETS,
[Iconic Markiplier pause, inhale]
so much ammro-
Come back here!
Come back here! (x2)
Don't run away!
oooh sorry for you,
[remorseless mumbling]
not really
Alright...
[under breath]
Where you guys at?
It's-
it's a REALLY good thing that they offer so much ammo
because without it I would be sooo screwedd.
Man, I would be doing so much worse than I am now.
[monster rawr]
Ow!
Son of a bitch!
Wanna mess with me?
[punk-like]
HUH??
Blam! I don't know what happened, but
his face exploded.
[Facility Voice: Demonic presence eliminated]
[Facility Voice: Lockdown disengaged]
Cool!
I didn't even know anything was locked down!
Is that what always happens when I clear out one of those pulsating gooey-goos?
Can I get up there?
Thank you.
Wait, was this where I came from or is this where I'm going?
I'm trying to find secrets around here-
this is where I came from, so there's gotta be something else down here...
that I can enjoy...
In terms of secrets, because...when I went-
whoa-
hello!
What're you doin' here?
Where is he gonna lead me?
'ight, okay...that's cool and all,
[sweet, sensual inhale]
(just look at that nose)
Is this where I'm supposed to be going or is this just a side-track?
Because I think I'm supposed to be able to get back, but...
that kinda leads me to another area.
Well, might as well find out.
Any day now.
It's the future, and
we still have to wait for slow-ass elevators.
(true doe)
Oh, some things never change.
Like...war!
And things of that nature!
(fallout.mp4)
Alright,
there's gotta be something else here.
Also, uhh...
I was testing out another game, and apparently
the triple-shot that I had before?
Or, the option of getting the triple-shot as opposed to the explosive shot
might have been a little bit better.
And I'm not sure.
Oh!
...wait,
but
does this just mean I can change it out or do I have to
do this now?
I was just talking about this.
Alright, you know what?
Alright, I'mma try this one because I was just testing it out before and it was
really, really kinda clever.
Like, the way that it works.
I-It obviously spends more ammo, but that's not gonna
be a problem if I keep
slicing ammo out of people with my chainsaw.
But hopefully...
Oh, a yellow keycard.
How convenient! I needed this-
are you gonna..come to life?
(yah man boo)
Hello...well, that almost scared me.
Sorry.
Sorry. (x2)
Sorry. (x3)
'kay...
Helloo.
Thunk.
Man, that was very Alien: Isolation™.
But, the thing about this is
it fires three in a quick burst after loading 'em up in there
and it's REALLY convenient for clearing rooms.
And actually, killing those stronger dudes.
Hello,
[condescendingly]
don't even try to swipe at me.
Thank you! Goodbye.
Aalright, who do we got?
There's a yellow keycard access-point somewhere  around here.
...like that one.
But there was another one.
I believe, anyway.
And if I can get to that first, then that could probably give me some secret stuff.
So lemme go back, I'm gonna cycle around...
over heeeeeeere,
and hopefully up here is going to be something of which I can uuuse.
Although I don't know if this is just gonna lead me back to there anyway,
but I just wanna make sure.
Because if I can get secrets...
I would rather do that than anything else.
[Facility Voice: Access granted.]
[sing-song]
Thank youu~!
[under-breath]
Karen, I believe, is your name..?
I have no idea.
I just name every computer voice Karen.
Hello...
oooh!
[reading from monitor - everything under "Area lockdown override"]
Well, I'm not gonna do that!
I'm just the Doomguy!
An utter badass that only cares about...
...blowing up demons.
Also, I did wanna note:
Uh, something that I overlooked in the first episode...
Well, I mean it was staring at me right in the face
I just didn't say anything about it,
was the, uh
was the fact that...
Right in front of me-
like, right in front of me when we got our suit of armor.
[Karen: Access granted]
It was noted- it was noticeable, that the
armor was
EMBEDDED in rock.
It was LITERALLY encased in stone,
and someone had broken it open.
[holographic man rudely interrupts spiel]
[very begrudingly]
uuuuUUAAHH
Oh, stupid business drivel- is this a new weapon? Hell to the yeahh!
I'm just gonna get three health points injected into my arm.
Good. But this armor was embedded, EMBEDDED, in stone and someone had dug it out and excavated it,
as if both I... and the armor... were hidden away, in rock, and we were excavated out.
Notice that in the beginning, my character had demonic symbols etched into my skin, branded,
if I am the original Doom guy, which,
I would be led to believe that it is, and this is actually a continuation of the story,
*laughs sarcastically*
"the story", from the original game,
then, we were sealed away, LITERALLY sealed away,
like, to protect someone, or to be excavated later for protection,
I'm not 100% sure which is true, and I'm not sure a 100% which is scarier, or cooler,
I-I'd like to think that we were locked away and encased somewhere in hell,
and then brought back to Mars, SOMEHOW,
to be utilized as a weapon of pure badass-ness.
Oh, hey! How's it going?
Well, first off let me show off the cool new tech- that's not- there we go.
BA BA BUM!
See? How cool that is? BOINK!
It's much more efficient at killing these dudes.
BA BA BIM! Thank you.
I mean, I won't be able to get health out of them- Woah.
*laughs* What'd that guy do? Just a death throw?
Alright, so now, I've got- yeah, heavy atholobleh- thh- heavy, heavy athault rithle.
Oh, that's much better! OH, that, that is delightful.
I probably shouldn't stand next to... the exploding cans.
[low health beeps]
Sorry, I just, I just got really- What the?!
Was that me? Was that someone over here?
Or am I just losing the ranged game?
Probably that one.
Woah!
Hup!
Can I get- Woah! Goddamit! I'm not doing well.
I should be doing a little bit better.
That's what I- every time I get a new weapon I just kinda play around with it when I should be paying attention and actually doing something important with my life.
Ba Ba Bum!
But inst- Woah! What the fuck are you d- Woah! What the fuck is that?
Alrighty then. Have one of these!
Ooo-kay. Woah, this is getting way dicier than I thought. There's people behind me, there's people in front of me,
there's people all around me. That ain't good.
Woah, woah, woah, woah! Ease up there, ease up there! I'm just trying to get used to everything.
Calm down! I gotta put on a show for everybody out there.
Bla Ble Blem!
Alright. Can I get some ammo please? *sing song* Thank yooo-OHHH MY GOD!
That's a lot of ammo! *demonic laughter*
Alright. That's enough ammo for now.
Boink!
That's the thing about the triple shot, I gotta, I gotta use it sparling-  SPARINGLY- Woah!
Sparingly compared to, uh, my other things because,
if I just use it to spray I'm gonna run out of shot gun bullets like, in a jiffy.
Hep Bep!
Man, that guy with the frickin' like, shield, is messin' up my steeze.
No, you do not. I can charge up an attack too.
HUP! Alright.
There we go. Got him. Got that! And gone!
Okay. Now we're doin' better.
What else is here? What is that?!
What IS that?! Is that quad damage?
OHHH! I want some!
What is this?! YES!
Oahh, yeah! I got a berserk pack! I love a berserk pack!
C'mere! Hey, hey c'mere! I wanna talk to ya!
What's in here? AEEAAHHH! *laughing* Oh my Goddd. Holy shit.
Hup! Sorry buddy. Didn't mean to do that.
I mean I totally meant to do that actually a 100% intentionally, but,
it was just unfortunate that you had to be on the receiVING END OF IT!
Ohh shit.
MORE?!?
Boink! *thrilled evil laughter*
That's so cool. I totally wasted that opportunity but that was awwwesome.
That was awwwwesome.
Oh, how do I get that armor over there?
See, I'm just passing secrets right by, left and right. It ain't good, it ain't quality. You guys deserve better.
Though I think it said something about a Praetor suit upgrade, which is kinda the thing that I've been missing out on.
See if I go into my, ahhh, menu here,
I can see that I've got both of these technically equipped, and this what I had the option of doing in the last one.
I could have upgraded these, and I have the option of going between both.
So I'm going to switch back to the explosive shot,
because I don't have... enough ammo to be tossing out the other one infinitely.
And now THIS is the upgrades, uh, section for the armor.
Where I can get more environmental damage resistance, area scanning; so I can see people behind me, y'know more...
*reading* ...upgrades improve equipment capacity and charge time, all that stuff, powerup effectiveness,
and then speed of certain actions which would be SUPER cool because Doom guy
*hoarsely dramatic* IS FAST AS FUCKKKKK.
And he's super duper quick on everything that he's doin' so, switching back to explosive shot because the shotgun is my jam.
I mean eventually I'll get the super shotgun, which is the double shotgun, and it looks like there might be...
...a secret up this way.
Can I blow this out?? Nope, okay- oop! Can I go up here?
Ah! Come on! You can get up there!
Stop being such biatcch about it.
There's gotta be a secret over here. And I'm hoping it's an upgrade token.
Okay, hello. Where the hell am I going?
Restricted Area?! I'm such a rebel! Breakin' rules left and right!
No one can tell Doom guy what to do! Doom guy DA BES'! DOOM GUY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT HE'S DOIN'!
[To bloody corpse] Can you give me an upgrade token? How bout this?
Hep! *small fart noise* Hrrr bleff!
This better be a secret, this better not actually be the way I was supposed to go.
Was that actually- that was actually the way that I was supposed to go.
Here I was, thinkin' that I was special and someone really cool, and understanding about the things that I was doing,
and I was just being a doof.
I was just being goddam doof.
[Dr. Samuel over P.A.]
Dear God, Dr. Samuel Hayden! What a dick!
*imitates deep voice sarcastically*
UHHH I'M GONNA HELP YA, AND YOU'RE GONNA HELP ME. BUT I'M GONNA STOP YA FROM HELPIN' YOURSELF.
SO DON'T EVEN TRY, DOOM GUY,
YOU'RE NOT SMART ENOUGH TO THINK ABOUT THESE THINGS, ASSHOLE.
So I was supposed to...
*shamefully* actually go this way. Which kinda robs me from the glorious exploration and smartness that I had in my brain.
Cuz I haven't found a single secret.
And they've probably been glaring at me right in the face, which, I will readily admit,
I'm not too keen on observing the things that I need to observe when I need to observe 'em- yeah this was the-
this was the elevator that I just about went to before but didn't go up for some fucking reason cuz I'm so-
Maybe they're- hang on.
Maybe, maybe there was something up there and I just went the wrong way to it.
And I'm'anna, I'm'anna, I- I'll be back guys, jus- hold, hold on! You hold those fireballs!
Aha! Here?! Over here? Yesss. *gasps* YESSS!
I got another secret! I knew it! I knew there had to be a secret down here.
YAY! Aww, fist bump little guy!
*laughs* Have a good- He did the balalalaluh fistbump!
*sniffs* What a cutie!
Alright. Doom Marine Model.
Haaaaa-Boink!
Um, where was I supposed to go? *loud noise* Woah! Who did that?!
Who the hell?! *same noise again* What the?!? Who thinks they're clever, huh?
*and one more time* Who thinks they're so cool that they can throw fireballs at me?
*another one* I'll be right with you before I get these things.
Hi! How's it goin?!
Boink!
I'm just gonna throw one of these, take that with ya, have a good day. Thank you.
Alright. Anything in here? Chinese food? Apparently leftover from some guy's good day.
*high pitched* Boink!
Umm, was I supposed to go in here?
Well, I don't know if I was supposed to go in here.
Of course I was supposed to go in here! Check point just got reached. Cuz I'mmm a big dumb doofy doo.
*fart noise* Thank you for the bullets.
Hup! Okay.
Woah. God damn it those imps.
They're kinda hard to see. I don't have a flashlight to be able to tell me exactly when *daffy duck voice* sumthin stharing at me right in fronth of my fathce.
There we go. I hope I'm going the right way.
That's the thing about this game.
Like, I think I, uh, I-I- I never seem to be going the wrong way, no matter what I'm doing, I seem to be always headed in the right direction.
Which is kinda cool, boink!
Aw, that didn't do nuthin'.
Hup! Thank you!
Sorry.
Kay- Oh I thought that guy was dead! I thought his whole head was like exploded off of his body!
I didn't know that he still had hope!
[low health beeps]
Woah! Seriously, stop doin' that.
Woah, AHH! That was not what I meant to do!
I didn't mean to do that!
Woahhh, I did something wrong! Sorry everybody!
Woooo, I wasn't paying attention. I was trying to saw him and then he was already dead and then I sawed nothing and then-
*deep inhale* That wasn't good.
Haduhduhduh!
*increasingly childish tone* Stop! Stop it!
Stop it! Stooppp it!
Stoooooppp it!
Okay, we're back! We're back in it to win it this time and we're not gonna suck it up.
I mean, we might suck it up, definitely migh- might do that.
C'mere you! I wanna punch you! Hehyehyuh!
Nope! Not gonna happen. Not todayy.
Not todayyy!
*singing* NOT TODAYYY! Ohhkay there we go.
Blumpf!
Blumpf.
I could, I could just go to this- Oh, hello! What're you doing up there?
Stop being a doof! How do you even getting me?
(nice grammar, Mark)
Ookayy, he's just going to fall over then. *laughs*
Is this a window or is this- ohhh, it's not- WAHHHHH!
[own bomb explodes in face] [low health beeps]
I did it again with the goddamn wrong crouch button.
That's gonna catch me more than anything else was.
Hey, I was almost in there!
Wh- ohhhh there's a staircase right here that woulda been-
*deep inhale* MUCH more advantageous than what I was trying to do which was just a whole bunch of stupidness.
Okay! So now that I'm low health, *laughs* let's get into the next area, huh?
Is there a health meter? I gotta be real careful about things.
I don't just sit in the corner and regenerate like most games.
Isn't that funny how most games, like, we've gotten used to the idea that we're just gonna sit in the corner and magically our health is gonna climb back up out of nowhere?
Well, I mean this one, health magically climbs up outta nowhere because it pops outta demons' bodies,
but I'm not gonna question that. It's a bit more of a... active process than waiting.
In my opinion.
[Dr. Samuel over speaker]
Mark: *childish voice* IT'S CHWISMAS!? FOR ME?!
I don't know I've got three health left, also, I'm infested with demons, so I think I'll be fine.
What- Oh! This! *laughs* I didn't even know what you were talking about!
Ah! It looks like the eye of Sauron but I'll put it up my butt if you insist on it!
Here we go! Don't know what it is.
*fart noise*
That's probably the best way to do it. Very delicate alien, demon technology and it's gonna be fine.
Okay. Route power system. OooOOOooo. UhooOOooo.
Okay. * reading* Permanently increases maximum armor capacity, permanently increases maximum health capacity or ammo.
Well, armor seems to be chewed away in two seconds, so for now I'm gonna go with health, because...
that seems to be my biggest problem.
I only seem to ever fight on health, so, let's try that.
And armor doesn't seem to be as readily available.
YAY! I got twenty-five more healthy points!
[Dr. Samuel on speaker]
Mark: *scandalized* Ohh!
Oh! That's you!
[Dr. Samuel over alien skype call]
Mark: Thank you!
Who's VEGA? You mean from street fighter?
[VEGA: disembodied computer voice]
Mark: Oh!
[Dr. Samuel making shitty excuses over alien skype call]
[VEGA: disembodied computer voice]
Mark: Huhhh.
[Dr. Samuel over alien skype call]
Mark: I don't know about that, I seem to be able to survive A LOT of things because as I've said many times, I'm an utter and complete BADASS.
With no limitations on what I can do and I'm going to take pure hell energy inside of me, and it's gonna be greaaaattt.
Look at that tiny ass helmet. I got a big head if my helmet's as big as I think it is.
Anyway. So now we're gonna go forward and we're gonna be a little bit better about things. Because that's what I've been having a problem with.
Bein' good about what I'm doin'! Huheejhee.
Man, I only found two?
Where are the elite guards?
I don't know where that is! Well, Goddamit!
I didn't complete all the challenges because I didn't find one more secret.
I'm really gonna look in this next level because,
*inhale* something about the secret's in the game, in the original doom, it was always like a false wall,
but, in the original doom, there was a lot less detail in the level so it was easier to tell what thomething was,
as opposed to just climbing up and finding a little nook and cranny, which,
I'm okay with finding, I can do that! But when it comes to uhh...
circumventing certain areas, I might have a bit of a problem, because as,
AS you guys have known, like, watching let's plays, obviously,
50% of my brain is coming up with the bullshit that's flowing out of my mouth.
And I coulda pressed space at anytime and it woulda been fine!
But, when it comes to using my brain to try to see what's in front of my face, it can,
it's so many times throughout my time on youtube that there's been something LITERALLY, standing adjacent to me,
and I do not see it, because I am just that dumb.
Or actually I'm not that dumb, It's just that, like, I concentrate too much on the wrong things.
(HUGE VOICE CRACK) Ooh! This looks bloody and disgusting and something horrible happened here!
[VEGA: speaking inside helmet]
Mark: Ohhhh!
Mark: Cooool. That's neat! Participating in combat will now reward-
[Dr. Samuel rudely interrupting Mark's reading through helmet comm]
Ookay, Why not? You made the security systems that seems like something that they should be able to be overridden.
And you think he would have had some automated response to a demonic invasion bes-
Oh! That looks, that's fascinating.
*reading* Find and kill as many "demales" (Demons) as possible to maximize your combat rating.
Okayyy.
Why is there this on the ground is this iiimportannnnt, mhmmm!?
Did somebody leave this behind while they're playing demonic hopscotch?
Ok, *singing* hellooo! Welcome to the party.
Ennnnghh,
YA BOINK!
Got 'em! Ok... GOTEE! *low voice* Okayyy, HUUUNNGH!
Hello? Anybody in here? Anybody secret? HELLO!
Wooooohh. Micro Missiles?! Hot tits, *laughs* that sounds awesome!
Um... I got- I li- I like explosions. I like explosions a LOT.
BOINK!
Why do I gotta be so mean to little bubble butt over there? I think I woulda be a little bit nicer.
Okay, what'd I get? Environment foundry. Well, let's read up about the foundry.
*reading* Congratulations new advocate,
Mark: *goofy voice* Thank you!
*Reads words on screen for long time* (doesn't know how to grammer words goodly)
Too much words
Soooo many words
(Deep breaths Mark)
*Voice crack*
*gibberish* *gives up*
Okayyy! This is a cult! If anybody had any doubts about that, this is friggin' cultish,
And AWESOME! BOINK!
Uh, BOINK.
*high pitched* BOINK!
*ascending notes* BOINK. BOINK. BOINK.
Am I getting a combat rating? I thought there was gonna be something on my hood about it.
Ohhh, I see it at the top right, Ok.
I do see something about it. But before I go over this way I need to, I need to explore a little bit back,
because I'm fairly positive... What the hell happened to them??
They blewed up from another demon.
Hey buddy. You killed my friends! How could youuu?
Okay. I'm gonna go back real quick because there's something that else that I need to see.
Gas leak? Well, that doesn't bother me (Farts A LOT) I'm in a fricken enclosed environment.
There's a secret up there but I don't know how to get to it.
God, I wish I had a flashlight!
What's over there? That sounds cool, what's down there that sounds cool, can I go down there?
Do I have options on where and when I can go to places?
Probably, here we go... Boink.
Okay... Boink...Nothing seems to be stopping me thus far.
Nothing seems to be telling me to go one way or another, it all just seems to be conjoined.
And...
Free roam.
Which admittedly is kinda awesome
I like the...
I like the ability,
to kinda be my own boss in terms of the directions that I go,
at least initially.
But then...
That probably leads to me being lost and so confused.
But not right now.
Anybody here?
*Shoots hater in the face*
Huh...
*misses*
*misses* (2x)
*amazing shooting skills*
Boink
Ow
You thunk me.
Huh.
So I'm just trying to take it in,
and try to figure out exactly were I'm supposed to be going
Woah
Hello...
OW! My balls
Uuummm
Uuuhh
Man...
That's so weird
It's just all-
Ooh, hello!
AH! I found one!
Ohh, ok, I get it
So I'm supposed to be...
AAAH I see, I know
I get it
I'm just supposed to be uh...
Going around and finding these four things
Woah!
*laughs* HELLO!
Nice move bruh
Nice move dying too
WHOOOP
I GOT IT
I'm just supposed to be going around and finding these things
So this IS an open environment
Which is kinda cool
I like that a lot
Hey buddy
Whoops missed right there
Alright, what else we got?
Who else wants some?
I can make it *makes weird noise*
Boink
Woah
OOW shit, not what I wanted
Eeup!
One health left, that's always good
Shobuhdobup
Woah, who's got the lasers?!
WOAH! Who's got the laser?!!
Oh, it's a different dude
Ooh, different guy [low health beeps]
I wanna fight you
YEEESS
SLAAAAYYY
Thank you
All right
I gotta get outta here
I gotta... Woah
I gotta be a little smarter about what I'm doing
WHOOPS nope, not smart
BOOOAAAAH
*Dies gracefully*
Nope, I'm dead
*singing* Ahhdiidiii- Okay, take twooo!
This time with more smartiness!
Oh, no! He was tryin' to run away! What a little bitch.
Oh, there's that other guy.
Whoop!
Whoop! There ya go!
Okay, what are you, what ARE YOU?!
Why do you look cool?
You're not supposed to look cool, I'm the only one that can look cool, ya dick!
Ya dingus!
BOINK!
Ran outta ammo at the perfect time to kick your ass.
Okay, I got one down.
Good for me, right? I did good!
[Karen: Demonic threat reduced by: 25 percent]
Mark: Huh! Funny, it's exactly 25% down!
I killed one gore nest!
I can't do math because me am only kill.
Okay, I don't think I can make that jump.
I mean, I'm amazing, but I'm not that amazINNGG!
Oh, God. Didn't think I was gonna make that.
Another stupid way to die- OOH!
There was- I didn't even see that over there.
I'm gonna go get that armor, that's probably a secret.
HUUPPP! Thank you.
Where'd you go? Hey, get back here!
BOINK! Well, your mistake. Sorry!
Okay.
HAP! Hadouken!
Ha- Holy shit!
Errrr fuck!
There we go! Anddd... ouph *fart noise*
*garbled voice* KAYYYY. I GOT IT.
Good for me right? OH SHI-FUCK-AHHHHaaaHHHHhhhh
GOD-FUCK-DAMMIT- FUCK MEEEEE!
*high pitched paniccing* AHHHHhhhhhHHHH! AHHHhhhHHHHhh! I BURNED ALIVE!
(NUUUU, YOU SKIPPED THE EASTER EGG!)
Okay, well that was, well...hang on!
Everybody hold your horses!
*holds horse*
It's fine! It's fineeee!
Okay, I'm back now!
Hup!
wOOaaHHhhhahHHhoh! Woah, hey, woah, woah.Okay.
HAHAAAAAAA BOINK! Got it. Ok.
So I CAN make those jumps. That's good to know in my brain hole.
And also I upgraded my weapons. Um, I got uh, bigger BOOM!
...on my... shotgun...NO, I got faster recharge time on my shotgun.
And then I got uh, more efficient missiles on my uh, missile launcher.
Which I don't know how it works, but I wanna know.
So, I need to get the blue card. So, I'm gonna go back the way that I originally went, over here...
to try to explore if there's another gore nest over this way.
Which I bet there is.
*barely audible* Woah, what was that?
I thought I saw something over there, but apparently not.
Okay. *high pitched voice* AH! OH NO! OH NO!
Boink!
Sorry buddy. Okay.
How do I do missiles?
WOOoooOO! *weapongasm*
BLAH! BLAH! BLAH! BLAH!
Why are you fighting? Stop fighting! Be nice!
Wooo!
Why was he fighting them?! That's so cool!
I mean, I know, one of the coolest things in the original doom,
was the fact that if you managed to get them to shoot eachother,
they WOULD fight eachother. And I hope that carries through this one, because that would just be radddd.
[Karen: Gas leak detected]
Mark: Uhuh. What about a gas leak?
[Karen: Access denied]
Mark: Yeah, I'm not very clear, am I?
I'm not very good at this security thing.
*sing songy* Hellloooo!
*holographic man screaming in agony*
Mark: [To demon] Where'd you put him, buddy? Where'd you put him?
I remember you! Hell knight!
Hell yeah, hell night!
Where you goin'? Where you takin' him?
Take 'em back to your lair?
Is that what you're gonna do? Like the Wampa,
or whatever it was in Star Wars? Okay.
[Karen: Warning - core temperature rising]
Well, that didn't, that didn't- that didn't explain where you're goin'.
That just kinda was creepy a little bit. But okay, whatever.
Can I make that jump?? Hell no!
*disgruntled* If I had double jump I could.
Hap!
A-Boink! Okay.
So, there's gotta be a place that I can get double jump because I remember in the intro sequence about this facility, they sub-
said something about like, plyometric boots.
Hello!
Woooo! This is an upgrade token.
Hell yeah!
ALRIGHT!!
So I am going to geeeeet...
*under breath* Improving the effects of powerups, navigational system,
*long whale noise*
Okay! I'm gonna get the area-scanning because I wanna be able to see what's going on around me.
Cool! Secret sense! Oh, I want that! *subdued* I don't have any upgrade points though. Dammit!
*tear filled voice* Why's life gotta be so hard? Oh, well.
Kay, got that...
Huup! Boink!
Okay there's gotta be another way around here that I can do what I need to do.
But I don't know where that is.
What am I doing up here?
Was I- was there reason to this- was there a point to this?!
Huup! Oh, there we go, okay.
Kay, that.
Now what?
Okay, why am I climbing back up? I jumped down for a reason.
Or I thought I jumped down for a reason- OHHHH! To get to the other side! Okay, I gotcha.
I got it, I got it, I'm in it, I'm with it. [The name of Mark's first sex tape]
Hello. You're the guy! Gimmee that! I'll just take that- from- thank you, sir! Have a nice day!
*makes brief noise of self-reproach*
AHHHhhhh! I'll- I'll be with you in a second, sir. Thank you.
Kay. Got this. This is gonna be delightful.
Lemme just flop that on there.
Perfect placement. It's almost as if I've done that before.
Good thing that doesn't bother me and I'm such a badass.
Oh, well. Whatever.
[Karen: Gas leak stopped]
Cooooollll, hooowwww?
I don't care.
Hup! Okay.
Lemme just remove this, *monster screams in torment* that's what was causing your pain there buddy-boo!
[Monster, probably: I don't believe that man's ever been to medical school]
Who wants to play? Anybody want to play?
Whoa, where'd you come from?
Woah. I kill 'em before I can actually save ammo.
Whup! Too much!
Whoops. Dayum, I killed him wayyyy quick.
I need to be a little more efficient about my ammo consumption- What are you shooting at, you dick?!!
*nasal voice* Doannn't even think about it.
Whop! There we go.
God, they're so hard to see.
Just standing in the darkness.
Huup! Okay.
I'm gonna have to cast all my magic missile in the darkness. [Mark's second sex tape]
Got 'em.
Oh, that was it? That was it?! Come on guys! You gotta be a little better than that!
[Karen: Demonic threat reduced by: 50 percent]
Awww, come on man!
"Be a little more badass, fight a little harder," says the guy who just died a million times,
over and over again, and hasn't found a secret yet.
Why haven't I found a secret? *tear filled voice* I don't know. *sniffs*
What is that? *reading* Core heat maximum threshold. Okay.
Alrighty then.
Well, enough standing around in a bunch of blood.
Time to get to business, I suppose.
Hmm.
Alrighty then.
I'm outta here!
God, where are all the secrets?? Why am I having such a tough time finding secrets?
I don't know. I'm a disappointment to everybody.
Hiii!
Sorry!
I don't want any girl scout cookies, not today, thank you.
Can I go down there? No, I've been down there.
I've been down there before, umm,
I haven't been there but I don't have the blue key card.
I don't think I've been...down this way.
I dropped down here before...
Huwp! Come on.
There we go.
Kayyy
Woah! Ah, Goddamit not one of you again.
Woah! Gah-
[low health beeps] *intensifying* Woah, woah, WOAH, WHAT THE FUCK?!?!!?
EXCUSE ME?! What the hell happened there??!
WHAT WAS THAT BULLSHIT?!
That seriously, like that was weird. That was weird, right? I got-
I-I had no control over what I was doing for like a good five seconds before I died.
That was bizarre.
Alright, enough excuses.
*demon grunts in pain*
PUNK! Thank youu! Okay.
Enough excuses, no excuses, that's not what I'm here for.
I'm here for excellent game play, that's, that's what I do.
(Sure, Mark, whatever you say)
I gotta actually use my explosive shot when it comes up because otherwise I'm just gonna be floundering like an idiot and wasting shotgun shells.
Which is what I usually do, in the tried and true strategy that has gotten me through a lot of things in the past,
but HERE, I need to display a certain level of skill.
Is this a thing? Well, it's yellow.
I don't remember seeing a thing with a yellow door.
[about explosion shaking screen] Woah.
HUH!
Well, that's weird. Why's everything all explodey?
Mhmm. Seems like someone built this place very shittily.
Alright. Can I get up here this way?
*barely audible* Gotta be a way, right? HEP! EPP! *fart noise*
That didn't work.
How bout over there? HOAHH!
Nope. That ain't go- Oh! Hello!
What're you doin' here? What was THAT?!
Oh, Hey buddy! You gonna grab me?!
You're gonna grab ME?!
You're gonna TRY to grab ME?!!
Ya hell knight bitch!
Huh? You wanna fight?
I think he does wanna fight. That's, that's quite evident by what I'm seeing in front of me.
Babiddyba!
Ohhh- gonna bl- OHHHHH NOHOHO!
OH NOO YOU'RE DEAD!!
YOUR GIANT, STUPID, UGLY FACE GOT CAVED IN!
Eh- Boink! Kay.
Secret to that guy is just getting up on his ass.
Hup! Oh no.
Kay, get this guy...
and carve this guy up like a turkey! BAAAHHHHHHHH! Ah, man.
Too bad he was hiding all that ammo inside his skin.
That was his first mistake.
Alright.
I still didn't find another gore nest.
And I don't know how I'm gonna be able to get up there but I do have a yellow keycard, so...
*inhales* if I had to guess, the yellow keycard probably goes to the one area I have not been yet over here...
[Karen: Warning - core temperature rising.]
*makes plop noise with lips* Welp, who cares about that? Do I care? No, I do not.
Haabum!
Habum!
Habum! (x2)
Habum! (x3)
Thank you. Have a good day.
Kay.
Hup! There we go.
Man, I wish this ammo, er, this armor would keep a little better than it has in the past.
Boink! Ok.
Ahh, Boink! Nope! Ok.
Doink! Ok.
Where the frick is the yellow keycard entrance?!
*reading off screen* Stay focused, stay committed.
Rip and tear! I know! That's the only thing that I know how to do- WOAH! HEY! What the fuck?!?
Where'd you come from?!
What the hell is that all about, buddy?
Huh? You wanna be my friend-
*massive hit* [low health beeps] WOAHH, SHIT!! WHAT THE FUCK? WHERE'D YOU COME FROM?!
WHERE'D YOU COME FROM?
WOAHWOAHWOAHwoahwoahwoahhh... There we go. Thank youuu.
*laughs* Where do you- there's no up to go!
If he did a launching attack, HOLY SHIT, that was amazing!
Okay.
[U.A.C. spokesperson over P.A.]
Mark: Wooooo. Woooo! What is this!?
Wooo, this looks fun!
I don't know what it i- *inhales 90% of the air in the atmosphere* IT'S THE PLASMA RIFLE, HELL YEAH!!!
*nearly spitting in excitement* Oh, yes. Oh, yes pleaseee.
*reading off screen* Uhh, *mispronounces word* based off the *mispronounces word*,
design of the twenty-first century, this weapon delivers a rapid salvo of plasmoids that inflict both impact and thermal damage on the target.
That sounds cool!
That sounds like a lot of awesome words that I don't understand. But whatever.
Ehh, I wonder what Ima-
[holographic man rudely interrupts again]
Who the frick is the blind council? What kind of religious cult is this?
Very bizarre.
Oh! Samuel Hayden! I wanna know about him.
*deep inhale* *begins reading off screen*
*rushes words*
*utter gibberish*
*deeper inhale* *activates intense brain focus*
*still rushing*
*yawns or burps, I'm not sure*
Uhhmm, then he found cybernetic transference. Okay! That's...
...A THING. Good for him!
I don't understand... a lot of that. I mean, I get he transferred his brain into, uh, ah, robotic body,
which is, quite a development!
Hey buddy!
Ohhh. Look at that. Look, just look at that.
That's ni- Oh Woah! Wait!
Hey!
Hey, come on, friend.
Come on. Come on. Hey! Hey.
Come on, come on. Let's blehuh- come on.
Come on.
Come on. (x2)
Come on. (x3)
Come on. (x4)
Come on. (x5)
Ohhhh! There we go.
Wooh.
We suddenly got- I think when they handed me this gun they expected me to be able to take out a lot of these other guys.
But did they- did they not understand that I'm still a scrublord and tryin' my best at being terrible.
I'll get there eventually, but they need to have a little bit of lower expectations than what they've been showing me.
Don't do that!
Stop that! Stop bein' a dickkk.
So those, uh, triple cylinder things, they're... plasma ammo.
*high pitched* Oh!
Woooo. I found a secret!
[low quality Doom (1993) E1M1 music]
That one was hiding in plain sight. Hot damn.
Aww.
[low quality Doom (1993) E1M1 music]
I didn't even get my, uh...
I didn't even get my little fist bump there.
Interrupted it with jumping up on something stupid.
Can *gibberish* there? Can I get in there? Please? Please. Okay.
Do I need the yellow keycard or sumthin'?
[Karen: Warning - core temperature rising]
Mark: Okay.
Hey! Shotguu- *demon roars* It's cool.
Boink! Okay.
I'm assuming when I pull out that thing I'm gonna be a- havin' a run in with another hell knight
because they seem to wanna throw those at me a lot nowadays.
Don't know if I have the *sputters* means with which to do that!
Alright, whatever. Let's do this.
Come on I ain't no bitch!
*demon roaring in agony*
I ain't no *mixes pussy with wussy?*
Hep! Okay.
Thank you. Err, come again.
Got you. Okay.
*distorted demon voice says something incoherent*
Mark: [To voice] Dis- what? What'd you call me?!
What'd you say? Huh?
Why don't you say that to my face!?
Oh. Oh, shit! *laughs* I said it to HIS face!
Nice! I got a map.
Okayyyy. No grenades needed.
Everything's cool. *little gasp*
Hiiiiii! You're big!
What're you gonna do? NUTHIN!
Oh, eyyy, lemme just, lemme just, thank you!
I need to come up with a different death animation (I think he meant exclamation?) for you.
Because YOUU deserve better.
[Karen: Demonic threat reduced by: 75 percent]
Funny about that. I still don't think I actually used the yellow keycard so there's gotta be something else here.
This guy's got the blue one!
Cuz he's wearing the blue jumpsuit and color coordination is very important in this facility.
*laughs* I'm glad to know that one of the requirements for being U.A.C. personnel is being incredibly fashionable.
*loud "whaling" noise in the distance*
Mark: *tries to imitate noise, sounds like dying seal*
Oh no, they're keeping whales! They're keeping whales in here!!
How could they be so cruel?!?
Boink. Okay.
Aww, I'm at full armor. That never happens.
Okay, there's gotta be something else over here.
*same noise sounds again*
Mark: *imitates noise three times, each a pitch higher*
I actually, I-I- I honestly have not been looking-
[holographic douche strikes again]
Mark: Oh.
Well, that was convenient. I didn't expect to come across it that easily.
The hell happened?
Ow. Stop it.
Don't spin move me, don't juke me out!
Boink!
Who's there? Where are they?
I HEAR them! I hear demons. I don't see demons.
Hello?
Ahh! There's a stair!
Boink!
Hup!
Woah! Where'd you- woah, woah! Hello.
Nope!
Haap!
Hap!
HAP!
Balulu! Can I get some missiles on this bitch?
OOAAAahhhhh! Get WRECKED!
I'm gonna go behind ya this time! Ohohoho!
I must be good!
I should be overconfident and then try to display my skill and then fail miserably.
[To U.A.C. Spokesperson and Karen]
What was that? So many people were talking at once there.
Woahhkay.
[U.A.C. spokesperson over P.A.]
Mark: Something tells me I might have already seen Jessica.
And Jessica was none to happy about seeing me.
Alright.
At least we're getting more interesting enemies in part of this.
I just wish that I could actually see where I'm goin'.
Uh-oh. Why'd the music get awesome?!
I mean, I'm not saying it's a bad thing. But I'm just kinda curious as to why.
OOOHH! This looks like an arena!! I wanna fight here!
Holy shit yeah!
I wanna fight!
Do sumthin!
Cool.
Am I gonna fight something big?
Please tell me I'm gonna fight something big.
Ohhh, I wanna fight something big so badly.
You're not big!
You're not big AT ALL!
Nah, nah, nah! Nah- I said nah! Stop! Stop! Stop! Stop it!
Ahh, Stop it!
Alright, where- Oh.
Huh.
I hear somethin'.
Huh!
They can actually forget where I am for a second which is kinda cool.
Huhh. So, if I actually employed some strategy about that, I would, uh...
I would mislead them in diff- various directions before I actually-
Oh! That guy is a big guy!
OhhHHhh shit!
Whoops! That's not what I wanted!
I wanted that!
I thought I had my shotgun out!
I shot him with my measly pistol!
What kinda badass am I?
OHHHH! That kinda badass.
Huup!
'Scuse me, sir?
Heh. Runnin' away like a little baby!
That's what I thought...
Okay.
Anybody else?
Anybody else? (x2)
Anybody else involved with this shenanigans?
Oh, can I not go through here because I haven't killed all the demons?
I thought I cleared 'em out.
I think the rest are just afraid to actually face me.
Boink!
C'mere, stop running away like a little baby!
*condescending* Oh, no. It's you!
Whops! Missed that! Alright then.
Gonna... do a little bit of this.
Oh, it's two of 'em!
I remember in the original Doom when I was playing, uh...
the, the end of the first, um, like, y'know, uh, area.
Er, uh, first, uh, mission! Not mission. What's it called?
I can't- Why can't I think of the name right now because I'm trying to fight at the same time.
But the end of the first, umm, episode or- or whatever you wanna call it.
Yeah, When I- at the end of the first episode when you come across the two hell knights at once-
the first time I ever played that, I was SO unbelievably scared.
*realization dawns* Oh!
Oh, cool! I can change out that?!
By double tapping- Oh cool!
Okay, so by double tapping "R" I can change out from explosive blast to charged burst.
[Dr. Samuel Douche over helmet comm]
Mark: Okayy.
How do you know that? Somewhere nearby, that's awfully vague for a facility that you kinda RAN.
Okayy.
There's just mysterious places that people can camp out and then-
just in the certain con-condition of a demonic invasion they can just hide away.
Hellooo. Thank youu. I'll take that.
*sing song* Yes please!
*high pitched* Boink!
It's amazing how an upgrade token is just a little computer chip but that, uh, somehow makes me able to be more badass than I ever was before.
Boink!
Hello. Hi! How you doin'?
[Olivia recites numbers and words ominously]
Mark: *petulantly* I can say words and numbers too. You're not that special.
[VEGA inside of helmet]
*electronic noises as Olivia moves screen pieces*
[Karen: All power rerouted to Argent Energy Tower]
[Dr. Samuel biznitch over helmet comm]
Mark: Whyyy?
Kinda curious as to why that thing is that she's doing that.
*electronic noises ramp up exponentially*
[Olivia makes debatable statement]
Mark: I-I don't know who I was saving! I- I didn't think I was actually trying to save anyone.
I think you have a fundamental misunderstanding of what I'm here to do, which is kill absolutely everything that I come across.
Why do you think Dr. Samuel *ridiculously deep voice* HAYDEN, didn't come meet me in person?
Because he wasn't brave enough to stand up to Doom guy.
Woah. Where'd you come from?
Where'd you come from, where'd you go? Where'd you come from cotton eye Joe?
Hrrup! Oh, I'm outta ammo. Well, that's lucky for you.
Dropped like a stone.
Alright, anybody else?
Anybody else feel brave enough to come face me?
NO? Huh! Wonder why.
It's just enough to slow me down.
[Dr. Samuel Satan over helmet comm]
Mark: Hmm.
Does that mean that mean blow it up?!
Cuz that's my specialty.
I graduated summa cum laude in blowing shit up.
No? Okay.
*sing song* Gooodbyee!
Okay! That is pretty much all the time that I have for this episode.
I almost had a perfect score but I only got one, ONE frickin' thing!
*reading* Oh, death from above? Oh, I didn't even know that was an option.
Attack from abo-- I didn't- I did not know that!
"Kill three of the possessed with one explosive barrel". Ah, didn't know that either! I should probably look at these things!
But I did pretty good at the killing, but-
Thank you everybody so much for watching! Ahh, another episode is gonna come out pretty much every two days until this game is done.
This game is awesome.
And I'm really interested to see how the story's gonna wrap together and why this lady wants to blow up Mars?
I don't know! But a lot of people are dead and turned into demons, so-
Thank you again! And as always, I will see YOU, in the next video! Bye Bye!